gazprom ha aumentado la presión sobre
francia la medida del gigante energético
ruso de detener todas las entregas de
gas al contratista francés en ya partir
de este jueves ha generado preocupación
moscú es uno de los principales
proveedores de francia del combustible
fósil antes de la guerra de ucrania el
17 por ciento de las importaciones
procedían de rusia ahora se ha reducido
al 9 por ciento para muchos es una
fuente de energía esencial como para
esta empresa del centro de francia que
produce sopa embotellada por todo el
centro funciona con estos vaporizador es
se alimentan exclusivamente un
calentador de gas situado en el exterior
del edificio una reducción del
suministro este invierno podría llevar a
las empresas a un racionamiento
energético lo que supondría el fin de la
producción en centros como este el
gobierno francés dice que la situación
está controlada gracias a sus recientes
esfuerzos por diversificar el suministro
de energía el mayor impulso vendrá de
noruega que ahora suministra el 36 por
ciento del gas francés en las próximas
semanas argelia podría aumentar su
suministro hasta en 1 50% y eeuu ha
comenzado a enviar gas natural licuado
pero a nivel europeo incluso con todos
estos nuevos proveedores y más de todo
el mundo no será suficiente si rusia
cierra todos sus gasoductos las reservas
europeas no durarán todo el invierno o
no sé si este próximo invierno
tendríamos un déficit de 20 mil millones
de litros cúbicos
eso significa que europa se quedaría sin
gas a mediados de marzo
la muerte whitman antes de la invasión
de ucrania el 45 por ciento de las
importaciones europeas de gas procedían
directamente de rusia